[Music]
Bonjour Monsieur president poster
president madam thank you for taking the
time the basic idea mr. president was
that we speak to you because you're
going to be awarded the Charlemagne you
price on Thursday but we cannot limit
ourselves to speaking about Europe alone
because we have a very important topic
that's right you tried to save the
Iranian nuclear deal when you were in
Washington why did you fail I think the
most important thing is to maintain
stability and peace in the Middle East
in Washington and I have said this by
the way I had understood that President
Trump wanted to leave the agreement from
2015 and during our joint press
conference I had suggested that we work
on a broader framework and I'm very
sorry about his decision I think it is a
mistake and this is why we Europeans
have decided like we reiterated
yesterday to remain within the agreement
from 2015 as I reminded President
rouhani we negotiated and signed this
agreement and it allows us to control
the nuclear defense activity in Iran
under 2025 but this agreement needs to
be completed on nuclear activities under
2025 ballistic activities in the region
and regional activities of Iran in Iraq
Yemen and Syria when I was in Washington
I said to President Trump don't tear
everything up but if some things worry
you let's strengthen this framework and
he decided to create tension I think
this was meant to go beyond to something
broader this is what we have to do among
European countries with the EU
with United Kingdom's Germany and France
we have to reaffirm that we are attached
to the agreement from 2015 because the
Iranian regime cannot take this its
activities up again well you have heard
that they are stalling that's what they
said in their declaration of yesterday
there is no escalation and the European
decision allows us to stop activities
for now and to limit escalation and this
is why we have to work together with our
partners in order to limit an escalation
of tension in the region and this is
what we have been trying for months now
and this is also why we have to broaden
already the topics in order to bring all
the parties back to a larger security
and stability framework for the region
you are saying that the Europeans are
going to try to remain and in the
agreement and adopted but what does it
really mean without the United States
what is it worth without them is it a
proposal that's sufficient for Iran but
this is going to be our topic in the
coming weeks and months and it's the
mandate that we gave our foreign
ministers in the EU end in Iran to
propose well it's the agreement that we
signed is everything over no because one
of the signatories draws out but the
others are reaffirming and that they are
committed it is a pity because we had
anticipated and now we can regret his
decision but it's important that we all
remain obsessed by stability and peace
in the region the situation is very
different and our transatlantic
relations damaged well there are some
elements of tension but there are also
elements of very strong and
anchoring of computer the deepest sea
and I think we can go beyond this
through a larger negotiation that I
proposed already unless September during
the UN assembly with Angela Merkel and
Theresa May we want to work in this
direction and we have also plans on the
commercial level and I think this has to
be respected we are a very strong trade
power are the United States are an ally
partner but we have rules to abide with
the WTO rules and we have to respect
them and have others respect them as
well
it is very important that we Europeans
maintain the multilateral framework we
have true convergence and our views and
we work together a fight against
terrorism together with the United
States in Syria we are working together
in the international coalition in Africa
we work together in this Isle and Sahara
zone against Islamist terrorism so you
see we have some disagreements but
nevertheless and most importantly we
have a common interest the will to work
for our common security in the same
direction we are now at a historical
point and we have to and maintain this
multilateral order which we created at
the end of the Second World War and that
is sometimes in jeopardy we have to
create the strong motor literalism
as I said in Washington France Germany
and Great Britain negotiated together
with Iran now in Europe you have reform
ideas that we don't endorse are you
disappointed with Angela Merkel not at
all I am waiting for her reply this is
not our only topic that we talk about
Germany waited for a long time for
France to complete its reforms and I am
NOT here to give good grades bad grades
or to say I'm disciplined we work
together we are partners
yeah I think that the Chancellor and her
government is going to join us in this
historic moment and work together for a
stronger Europe and more United and more
sovereign and more democratic Europe
that's our challenge those who follow
the events I think you see that the
German government is not working as
quickly as you had expected because we
have a different method and we also have
different views view
speaking about EU finance minister but
Germany is not endorsing that everything
that you envision is not going to be
possible are you aware of that
well I never said that everything that I
proposed has to you have to take it or
leave it
all I have an ambition I make proposals
but I am convinced that it was my duty
to do so the current status quo in
Europe is bad for everybody our
sovereignty is being tested for
everything that's happening the Iranian
crisis trade crisis the challenges of
the digital world of internet energy
transition migration on our capacity to
protect ourselves we have to make
progress and we have to be a more
integrated European avant-garde I would
like economic government a minister but
you call it whatever you want actually
the end is what counts more than the
names I just want a Europe that is more
democratic and less bureaucratic I want
this Europe to be more United
concerning the essential points able to
protect itself against the big risks
stronger political integration in the
eurozone I mean a policy of solidarity
and responsibility because
in the last year's Europe was divided
several times division between the North
and the South because of the financial
crisis and economic crisis and then a
division between the East and the West
because of the migration crisis do you
think we can go on like that forever no
we have to create more solidarity in
front of all those dangers and that's
the reform that I proposed I am waiting
now for the German replying together
with the Chancellor we have the target
of replying of getting a reply in June I
am following the German political life
you have elections and new government I
think it would be a mistake to formulate
a reply that likes an ambition mr.
president I have a delicious question
for you I see you wing in Germany you
have often been called Jupiter or Caesar
one year into the presidency are you
still a superhero I have never presented
myself as such so I leave the
responsibility for this comparison to
you they are not always true I think
from the first day I have been working
hard I was elected president of the
French Republic by the French people who
made a choice between extreme right-wing
candidate and what I had to propose and
many thought that it would be impossible
to be elected on the strength of a
European program I know that my project
is a very hard to carry out and I have
been working without respite from day
one if you cannot manage for instance to
amend the treaty if Germany does not
have a solution and this is to conclude
if we don't find a solution does that
you still have a future I'm a fighter
and I never dwell on bad things I'm
going to put all my energy into
convincing and
advancing some more I think the best way
to convince is to do the job at home
that's what I said from the beginning
and this is why I waited until September
to give my proposals for reform and then
you have to explain to be humble to be
constant
I have no lessons to give I just say
what I am suggestion and then I have to
go on working and write some more and
until things are a reality I am NOT
going to choose that option that
scenario because I think that would be
dramatic for all of us and bad for
Germany as well Germany had the courage
and the strength of character to carry
out very deep economic reform already
ten years ago and benefited a lot from
the eurozone but the situation where we
are now it's not going to be able to
continue like that so even in Germany
should not remain in this situation
during the migration crisis Germany was
confronted by selfishness from all the
other countries and had this experience
now we have a more responsible Europe
where the countries are under pressure
to reform and so we need more
transparency more responsibility of the
Member States but we need more
solidarity in Europe on economy finance
a migration we need more sovereign
Europe that better protects itself
against the risk a more united Europe
and I really want your viewers to
understand that it's good for them thank
you very much